hey crazies have you ever wondered why
we have size no I mean really thought
about it why don't we take up space
asking this calls into question the very
nature of space itself it might seem
like a strange question so let's take
the slowly one step at a time
in a previous video we said this about a
tennis ball this ball is made of a
rubber shell covered in two nylon felt
surrounding a pocket of air each of
those materials is made of molecules
which are made of atoms which are made
of subatomic particles some of which are
made of even smaller particles on a
basic level we are made of the same
stuff as that tennis ball
everything is every atom on the periodic
table is made of protons neutrons and
electrons those protons and neutrons are
made of the same two types of quarks but
how big are quarks and electrons there
are actually a few different ways to
answer that it depends on what kind of
quantum physicists you are if you're
extremely cautious you might remember
what I said in the Planck video at 10 to
the negative 18 meters we reach the
smallest distance we've ever measured at
the making of this video
at which point you'd say probably we
need to know if your quarks and
electrons are at most 10 your negative
18 meter across that isn't any fun
though so if you're like me and you
don't want to sit on the metaphorical
fence there are two ways you can go from
here option 1 you could say it depends
on how its interacting with other
particles say an electron is in a
particular energy state like 3s it could
be anywhere that's orange therefore it
is everywhere that's a lunch therefore
that's how big it is which is
effectively the size of the entire atom
even if you use a photon to measure a
more specific position for the electron
you'll still have an uncertainty about
it
whatever that uncertainty is that's how
big the electron is but that's not very
satisfying nor is it particularly useful
option 2 Richard Feynman once said the
electron is either here or there or
somewhere else but wherever it is it is
a point charge what's that mean he's
saying particles don't have size here's
the basic idea now this picture doesn't
actually show the electron only the
probability of where it might be this
spot is dimmer so it has a lower chance
of being here that spot is brighter so
it has a higher
being there but wherever it happens to
be regardless of what uncertainty your
measurement might have it is only a
single point it has no size so how can a
bunch of things that don't have size
come together to make something that
does have size it's the space between
particles that gives everything size a
proton has size because it's quarks are
separated by some distance an atom has
size because of the space between
electrons in the nucleus
thinking like this still has its
problems though problem number one it
gives you the impression that somehow
space is empty when it's actually very
full the space between quarks is full of
gluons binding those quarks together
giving all atoms 99% of their mass
through a equals MC squared and causing
unstable quarks to pop in and out of
existence but gluons don't have any size
either so this doesn't solve our problem
it just makes the picture more
complicated so we're not going there
problem to the definition of a point
leads to some paradoxes a single point
has no size and zero dimensions it has
no length no width no height no surface
area and no volume it just is a line is
a collection of points it has one
dimensions a length but it has no
thickness a bunch of points make a line
and a bunch of lines make an area in a
bunch of areas make a volume or what you
might call a space unfortunately this
just brings us back to our previous
question so how can a bunch of things
that don't have size come together to
make something that does have size well
there are only a few ways we can
reconcile this solution one am i making
too many lists solution one maybe
something weird happens because space is
infinitely divisible for any two
different points on this line there is
an infinite number of points between
them this level of infinity or
cardinality is labeled with a frocked or
script C for continuum so somehow we
gain additional dimensions by having an
infinite number of lower dimensional
objects but you know me I'm always a
little hesitant to apply infinities to
the real universe solution to maybe
points have to be separated by some
unoccupied ballistas yeah
I said unoccupied oh I don't care if
it's not an official word as long as it
takes the idea out of my brain and puts
it into yours anyway I'm just saying
that an electron could exist here here
or here but nowhere in between that
might seem a little weird but it fits
right into the status quo of quantum
physics solution 3 maybe points actually
have sighs maybe they're not zero
dimensional if they make up a three
dimensional space maybe they also have
to be three dimensional but that brings
up a bunch of other questions what shape
are they if points are boxy what are the
length width and height
if points around what is their diameter
how do they fit together are they all
the same it's madness physicists are
currently working hard on it but it
might take a while what do you think the
solution is infinities mandatory
separations points with size or
something else please share in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video we discussed why
humans are the size they are cut my
response time
spasibo was wondering if octopus arms
behaving independently of the central
brain was anything like having your left
and right brain separated when human
brain hemispheres get separated they do
seem to behave independently in some
ways I'll put some links in the
doobly-doo about it but even then there
still does seem to be a single cohesive
consciousness you're still you mostly
you just lost the ability to do things
like properly identify objects and
octopus brain is different because it
benefits from the independence whereas
you are hindered by it yes I hope I
didn't come across harsh correcting knew
about squids versus octopuses I wanted
to save your question for comment
responses but also wanted to make sure
you didn't make the mistake with someone
less forgiving before I had a chance to
make this video David - one six eight
six that's why we couldn't just be ten
times taller and change our body
structure so we could handle it geronimo
current plan to respond with an answer I
couldn't have said any better we could
be ten times taller but then we wouldn't
be human this body structure is part of
what defines our species Elliott gray
can't get the attack on Titan theme out
of his head you're not alone Elliot
tetra carbon seems to have accidentally
star
a conversation about the metric system
math bases and Counting I got involved
and mentioned that technically we
already counted well if we really only
counted to ten then instead of saying
eleven and twelve we'd say one teen and
two team or as Chuck 32 would say first
teen and second team which you know I
think those actually sound better if
you're into that sort of thing you
should check it out and a nod to pav ik
your consistent encouragement does not
go unnoticed just wanted you to know
anyway thanks for watching see you next
time